Ben
[Müzik]
iptal en nerde sans eş
dersimizin konusu sayılar bitsel sayı it
sarın sayılar demek Almanca'da bir yere
12 arasındaki sayılara ezberlersin iz
gerisi kolay PDF dosyası ekledim Bununla
ilgili indirip çalışabilirsiniz Yine
oyun yükle üzerinden alıştırma
yapabilirsiniz öyleyse bir ile 12
arasındaki sayılara bir göz atalım
Burada okunuşlar da biraz sıkıntı
çekebilirsiniz O yüzden bazı
hatırlatmalar da bulunalım Örneğin eve
iyi harfleri Bunlar nasıl okunuyordu
bunlar aynı şekilde okunuyordu direyi
değil THY şeklinde okuma yapmamız lazım
ya da iyi w e harfleri yanyana geldiği
zaman da Bunlar uzun iyi gibi okunur
Ziya ben değil Zebani şeklinde okuma
yapmamız lazım Evet o harfleri ise o
şeklinde okunur neon değil Noel ve baş
harfinde s olursa Z olarak okumamız o
Steven değil zıbın gibi harflerimizi
seslendir elim Nuri Nuri
ya Ayn Sad xind
While While
Die Die
frau üns
üns
sex sex
zivin
zaman
naht
aht
knowing Noel
syncing ev ev
sörf sörf
13 ile 100 arasındaki Bütün sayılar
Almanca ters olarak okunur Bu ne demek
Örneğin 13 Biz burada önce 10 soru 3
ifade ederiz Ama Almanca'da bu ters
olmalı yani 3 ve on şeklinde okuma
olmalı Almanca olarak bakarsak senin ha
yerine Tayyip senin dememiz gerekir ve
Almancada bütün say bu bitişik yazılır
bunları a yazmayın şimdi yapmamız
gereken Demek ki üç dört beş altı
diyerekten arkasına on eklemek ama
burada atladığımız bir şey var bir
istisnai durum var o da nedir 16 ve 17
deki s harfini atalım en eklerini atalım
Ne kaldı xeş ezip Şimdi onları arkasına
yazalım Hayat Senin fiyatın funitin gibi
iddia etsin kayıt seyin ve fiyat seyin
Fiat seyin
bu simse insülin Hüseyin vize Hüseyin
zehrinin Zip şeyin zippsi
Nah senin ahse
innovance
insens iş Senses
bu dijitalin Nur bessan satış Noel and
Why i
sayfiye Jones sex
spınach tno insin ev sörf trypsin Fiat
Sahin funitin
zeytin zeytin ahsin non sensin sensin un
nokay marcondes Vay
keyfi Assassin's
zexs even aht noylan Senin ev sörf
titine fiyat senin fırt in zeytin zippsi
Nahsen innovance insens iş dersiniz sona
erdi da sonu ve azumi softem Vahdet
sarın of the about Evren sayıların gücü
üzerine kurulmuştur o
pitagoras yani Pisagor Bir sonraki
derste görüşmek üzere hoşçakalın